public schoolteachers in Denver expected
to return to the bargaining table later
today amid their first strike in 25
years Colorado is the seventh state
where teachers have walked off the job
in the past year with Denver teachers on
the picket line about 71 thousand
students and their families are just in
limbo Janet shamlian is outside East
High School in Denver with more on this
story Janet good morning to you Gail
good morning nationwide almost all of
these strikes have been over higher
salaries but here in Denver teachers
also want access to a pool of money
that's been set aside as incentive
bonuses for just some of the teachers to
be shared among all of the teachers in
the district thousands of Denver
teachers made their voices heard at the
Colorado State Capitol the educators
walked out of more than 160 Denver
schools Monday a last resort they say
after 15 months of negotiations I've
gotten into massive debt just trying to
play basic bills the dispute is largely
over the district's incentive-based pay
system which gives yearly bonuses as
high as three thousand dollars a year to
some teachers like those working with
students from low-income families or in
special education the union wants to
lower or eliminate some of those bonuses
freeing up money for overall teacher pay
I have a master's degree of 11 years of
experience I didn't expect to still be
in this place in life Denver Public
Schools says it's already made a
substantial offer to teachers a pay
raise of almost 11 percent the goal of
negotiations is for us to get closer to
the middle DPS is way past the middle in
terms of what we've offered at this
point the district is trying to keep the
schools open staffed by administrators
and substitutes cameras were allowed
inside one class where it appeared to be
a normal day but students posting on
social media saw something very
different
this scene inside Denver's East High
School a free-for-all in the hallways
outside many parents and students
supported the teachers and walk the
picket line with them all of these
teachers have second third jobs its
reduces the state says this is costing
four hundred thousand dollars a day no
idea how long it will last but a recent
teacher strike in Los Angeles went for a
week viana Janet thank you and we all
remember that strike in Los Angeles I
have to say I saw an interview with a
teacher in Denver who said that she has
to sleep in her car because she has to
rent out her house you can't afford
bills makes true definition of working
poor teachers should be well paid